bolivia decidió cerrar preventivamente y
durante una semana su frontera con
brasil cuya variante tiene al gigante
latino en crisis de casos lo confirmó el
presidente luís arce en su cuenta de
'twitter' y la medida que entrará en
vigor el viernes afectará una extensión
de 3.400 kilómetros de territorio
compartido en el caso de los viajes
aéreos o los pasajeros deberán
realizarse la prueba pcr y permanecer 10
días en aislamiento a su llegada
alemania necesita asegurar una mayor
capacidad de producción con los
principales fabricantes de vacunas kobe
19 previendo que se necesitarán
inyecciones repetidas el próximo año el
ministro de salud de james panel dijo
que no se sabe cuánto durará la
inmunidad y que el país avanzará solo en
el suministro si es que otros miembros
de la unión europea no ven la urgencia
reconoció también que en alemania el
camino para salir de la pandemia va a
ser más largo que en otros países
para ser y valiente que dijeron que su
vacuna tiene una efectividad de 91 por
ciento para prevenir kobe 19 citando
ensayos actualizados que incluyeron
participantes inoculados hasta hace seis
meses la inyección también fue 100%
efectiva para prevenir enfermedades
entre los participantes del ensayo en
sudáfrica donde predomina la nueva
variante llamada be 1351